the fomc reaffirmed its view that the  current zero to one quarter percent  target range for the federal funds rate  remains appropriate the committee also  updated its forward guidance for the  federal funds rate indicating that the  committee judges that it can be patient  and beginning to normalize the stance of  monetary policy this new language does  not represent a change in our policy  intentions and is fully consistent with  our previous guidance which stated that  it likely will be appropriate to  maintain the current target range for  the federal funds rate for a  considerable time after the end of our  asset purchase program but with that  program having ended in October and the  economy continuing to make progress  toward our objectives the committee  judge that some modification to our  guidance is appropriate at this time